hey everyone welcome back in this video
i want to discuss about five
technologies which you should know on
the web which are dying and probably
these are the minds which you have to
navigate around and not really learn a
lot of things about them let's go also
if you are new to this channel make sure
you like and subscribe to this video i
regularly post content on full stack web
development how you can become a better
programmer and increase your efficiency
as a developer so the first one is
pretty common you would have heard it
about as well a lot of times on maybe
some older videos or some blogs and that
is jquery now jquery was a very very
popular library in fact it is still at
the moment but it its use has been
gradually decreasing consistently now
this is important because jquery's a lot
of features and a lot of ease which it
bring or used to bring has already been
patched directly into the library of
javascript and not exactly on one to one
mapping but just take an example of
performing a simple network request if
you used to perform a simple network
request back in the days what you have
to do is create an xml http object
assign it certain callbacks and then
there's a bunch of code which you have
to do jquery made it very simple just
write dollar dot get or dollar dot post
and that's it that will perform the
thing but now with modern javascript you
have the fetch api you have promises you
even have library solutions like axios
so they make it extremely easy and
convenient native methods are present
now this has led to a lot of decline in
jquery's usage and to be honest it's
fine because we always wanted javascript
to be more powerful
in these fundamental features the dom
manipulation the network request and so
on it's best for the community but yeah
make sure that you double check if
you're trying to learn jquery in today's
time then re-evaluate your reasons why
you're trying to do that because it is
one of the technologies which i would
personally not recommend anyone to learn
if they're starting off learning
javascript from scratch the second one
is angular or js now this is different
from angular 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 or
whatever the version is at the moment
they just pretty much ship a new version
every six months but
angular.js was the actual
awesome
framework or the library which kind of
like created this spark which react and
view and swelt and all these other cool
kids follow right i think angular.js was
one of the first libraries as well which
i used personally on internet on
javascript and i had created like so
many tutorials and so many videos on
angular.js as well but angular.js is
officially dead declared by google as
well i had created a video on this last
year somewhere as well but angular.js is
dead it's basically at a state where it
will not receive any updates from the
team from the maintainers and you are
advised to shift to angular 2345 or
whatever the version it is now the
problem here is that angular.js and
angular which are the modern versions
are extremely extremely different there
is pretty much nothing common between
them i think google has actually made a
bad decision by naming them both the
same thing because it often causes a lot
of confusion in people that if you know
angular.js you can pretty much shift it
easily to angular i mean yes you can but
that is because your javascript
understanding is good not because the
frameworks are similar right so
angular.js is something you should be
very very very careful if you're
learning in today's time and here goes
all the work i did in the past for
creating those videos but that's the
truth it stayed and you should probably
not be learning it in today's time the
third technology which is dying and you
should be careful about is old
javascript syntax now this is for the
good right to be honest in some ways and
not good in other ways but for example
let's take a look at the chrome 91 what
they did in the in some card here i have
created a video so what they did in
chrome 91 is they tried to get rid of
all the alert prompt and confirm these
dialog boxes from a cross-origin iframe
execution right it's basically older
syntax right kind of i mean alert prompt
confirm have been there for the longest
time and let's say some chrome 100
version or chrome 110 version they try
to get rid of all of that then it's
basically you know just javascript has
got a major change so
although it's not as deprecating or you
know it's not like declining anything in
the old javascript syntax i mean most of
the old stuff on the web still works but
it's it's important to take a look at
and you know keep an eye out for these
things which chrome are doing or which
firefox are doing because these are the
browsers right whatever they do people
use them and whatever people use we have
to create or write code according to
that so keeping an eye on using only the
new features stable features but new
like cons led you know better code it
will not only just help you write better
code and more robust code but also
prevent you from using something which
is which might be deprecated right or
which might even be removed in coming
times like i'm not probably sure if
alert and confirm example was the right
one because they are nowhere near
deprecated or you know just bad in any
other browser except for chrome but the
move which google did in chrome 91 shows
us that they are willing to break the
web in order to upgrade the language
spec you know or just improve the
language engine so make sure you know
about that all right the fourth
technology which is dying real quick
super quick is http and it's not what
you think it's not the hypertext
transfer protocol which is dying it's
the protocol which is not secure now
over 70 of the websites today use https
by default this is an awesome news
because https predicts your identity and
your data transfer whatever you're
sharing it with the website so that your
isp or any other middleman cannot
inspect what you're sending but yep this
means that websites using http are dying
and by dying i mean it's just a
technology which is dying http without
ssl without tls where you see that s and
a green lock that is something which we
probably will not be seeing even right
now but even more so you would not be
seeing any website just on http which is
popular in the next four to five years
so this is something you should be
careful about https is free now it used
to be paid that you need to pay certain
amount to get an ssl certificate but
companies like organizations like let's
encrypt have just changed the scene over
the last five to 10 years i mean i
remember so many websites which i used
to visit which are just http and they
have all been turned into into https in
the last five to six years so http is
definitely dying long live https and the
fifth and the final thing which i
believe is a dying technology which
might be a little bit controversial is
client-side javascript apps like just
using react in production or just using
vue.js in production now hear me out
what i'm saying here in the time of 2000
to 2010 or 11 what used to happen were
these frameworks like php and all these
frameworks which did server side
rendering like ruby were super popular
now what they did is that they allowed
you to write code which would be dynamic
and it will render on the server side
and user would be presented directly
that page then when frameworks like
angular.js and react were invented and
used at scale a lot of websites shifted
to the paradigm of using javascript
bundles heavy javascript bundles on the
client side and deriving all the data
and the api and all that stuff from the
server now this was awesome because
servers did not have to spend or you
know process a lot of information on the
server they can offload it to the client
but this was really bad for clients
because now they have to have more
computing power more processing power
which probably is not
what clients should be doing right the
client should be having more response
time to the people they should be having
ample of cpu and memory to respond to
touches and stuff like this so from 2013
2012 2013 to 2017-18 there was this time
where a lot of people just shipped huge
javascript bundles and there was a huge
cry out loud on the web community that
web is kind of just bloated now then
from 2017-18 we saw a shift where what
we did is we took these technologies and
took them to server so react became an
xjs or any other variant where you
render react on server side view could
be linked as next node.js oversight
rendering was always available like
forever but you can understand about
these technologies now what you're doing
is you're trying to write the same react
which you used to write on front end and
ship say a three megabyte bundle but now
you're doing it on back end with next
chase and shipping uh 200 kilobytes of
page right now this is important because
this saves a lot of computation time of
the client and makes the website even
faster right now every website and any
website which is slow in today's time
even after having this best of both
world scenario where you can have the
best of both worlds having react like
framework at your disposal but also be
able to use the benefits of server-side
rendering is the winning edge so if
you're a company if you're a business if
you're a startup who's trying to develop
and optimize for things like performance
and seo and stuff like this google in
fact has a ranking factor speed is a
ranking factor in the search results now
so this is super important i mean if
you're somebody who's still having a
slow website in 2021 and you have a lot
of traffic you know you're getting from
search engines or people using your
website it's a huge loss of opportunity
if you're not optimizing it slow
websites are gonna die web is becoming
faster again and make sure you are the
part of it so yeah that's pretty much it
that is all i wanted to discuss if you
like this video make sure you give it a
like and subscribe to the channel thank
you so much for watching and let me know
in the comments below what you think is
a dying technology for you and do you
agree with all the technologies which i
mentioned that is all for this one and
i'm gonna see you in the next video
really soon
[Music]
you